PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SUCK IT UP, JOHN.
NNENNA'S CONFLICTS
WITH HER BOYFRIEND AT HOME...
I'M ONLY GONNA HATE YOU...
SPILLED OVER
INTO THE TOP MODEL HOUSE.
LAST NIGHT, AND SHE WAS
ON THE PHONE TILL 1:00.
NNENNA IS PERCEIVED AS BEING
THIS NICE, SWEET GIRL,
AND SHE'S NOT.
LONG-LASTING.
SEVERAL GIRLS STRUGGLE
AT THE COVERGIRL
COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
I DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT IT.
BROOKE WAS DRIVEN TO TEARS,
AND JADE PLAYED THE BLAME GAME
IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES.
YOU GUYS USED MY WORST ONE.
JADE'S ATTITUDE
KNOCKED HER DOWN
TO THE BOTTOM TWO.
JADE, YOU DON'T KNOW IT ALL.
BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS MOLLIE SUE
WHO WAS SENT HOME.
EIGHT GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
LIKE, I FEEL LIKE
I CAME TO THIS GAME
TO REALLY
GET THE BEST OUT OF IT.
THEY...
I WAS AT THE BOTTOM TWO...
AGAIN.
JADE, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
BECAUSE YOU PLAY THE BLAME GAME,
AND THE JUDGES WERE TURNED OFF
BY YOUR ATTITUDE.
I NEED TO REDEEM MYSELF.
I DON'T KNOW, SHE'S JUST
REALLY PISSING ME OFF.
LIKE, NOT SO MUCH JADE--
- LIKE, SHE WAS IRRITATING ME...
- YEAH.
BUT NNENNA.
LAST WEEK, I HAD A LOT
OF TROUBLE WITH MY COMMERCIAL.
LIQUID MAKEUP...
- (laughs)
- FROM MAY--
I HEARD A LOT OF LAUGHTER
IN THE BACK.
NNENNA HAS BEEN CALLING ME
A CRYBABY TO OTHERS.
BROOKE CRIES EVERY DAY.
DON'T THINK OF IT
AS A WEAKNESS.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY SHE IS.
"SHE'S A CRYBABY.
SHE'S THIS, SHE'S THAT,
LET'S LAUGH AT HER,"
AND WHO--I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
"SWEET AND NICE,"
BUT I HAVE A TEMPER, I DO,
AND NNENNA--I DON'T THINK
SHE LIKES ME.
AND THAT'S FINE,
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE HER EITHER.
♪♪♪
GOOD MORNING, GOOD MORNING.
IT'S ALL ABOUT
ACCESSORIES TODAY.
AS YOU SEE, WE HAVE HERE
HIGH HEELS,
A FEW BAGS,
HAND GLOVES.
MISS J. JUST SURPRISES US
WITH THE RUNWAY CLASS.
(laughter)
(cheering)
IT'S ABOUT YOU
WEARING CLOTHING
AND MAKING IT COME ALIVE A BIT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS
ON THE DETAILS TODAY
LIKE TAKING OFF JACKETS
AND GLOVES AND TWIRLING.
YOU KNOW, UNBUTTONING A JACKET,
IT'S EASIER TO DO IT
FROM THE BOTTOM UP...
BECAUSE YOUR HANDS
ARE AUTOMATICALLY UP HERE,
AND YOU CAN JUST COME OUT OF IT.
♪♪♪
OUCH.
MM, YOU HAVE TO BE QUICK.
OH, YOU JUST MESSY--
TRESSY MESSY.
LET'S JUST GET BACK, GO ON.
I THINK MY WALK
WAS PROBABLY THE WORST
AND JUST THE FUNNIEST
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS.
(laughter)
LESLIE--PRETTY GIRL SHE IS,
BUT TO ME,
CERTAIN THINGS SHE DOES
JUST TAKES THE "PRETTY"
AWAY FROM HER.
WHEN YOU HAVE GLOVES...
♪♪♪
NNENNA'S LAUGHTER
BOTHERED ME BECAUSE
I TRY TO RESPECT HER
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE,
AND I JUST FEEL
SHE DOESN'T WITH ME.
I JUST--I DON'T KNOW.
BROOKE, YOU GET A BIT LOST.
YOU GET A BIT...
♪♪♪
AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE IN THE WRONG
BECAUSE IT SHOWS IN YOUR FACE.
♪♪♪
MAKE THAT SKIRT DO
THE DANCE OF THE SEVEN VEILS.
SARA'S STILL A BIT AWKWARD
IN HER BODY.
SHE JUST SEEMS LIKE GUMBY
ON A BAD DAY.
SARA, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE ALWAYS TRYING
TO MAKE YOURSELF LOOK SMALLER.
IN FRONT OF US, STAND TALL.
OKAY, GIRLS,
SO, TODAY WE LEARNED
ABOUT MOVEMENT WITH GLOVES
AND ACCESSORIES,
BUT YOU STILL NEED
TO STEP IT UP
A COUPLE OF NOTCHES.
SO, TODAY YOU'RE GONNA GO
MEET THE TWIRLERS.
SO, GIRLS, GOOD LUCK,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE
DOUBLE THE TROUBLE.
WHAT, LIKE, A CIRCUS, OR...
LIKE, WHAT'S GOING ON?
I HAVE NO IDEA.
♪♪♪
HI.
HOW YOU LADIES DOING TODAY?
ASWIRL.
I'M RICHARD HARRIS...
AND I'M RON HARRIS,
AND WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU
"ASWIRL."
THIS MORNING, YOU LEARNED
FROM MISS J. THE MOVEMENT
OF HOW TO TAKE YOUR GLOVES OFF,
YOUR JACKETS.
TODAY IT'S ABOUT
YOUR BODY MOVEMENT,
MAKING THE GARMENT FLOW.
OH, WE CAN'T WAIT.
WE'RE SO EXCITED.
WE TAUGHT TYRA THE SWIRL,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO TO YOU TODAY.
RON AND RICHARD--
COUNT DRACULA
MEETS A HAIRDRESSER.
THEY'RE AWESOME.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU ARE THE NEXT...
TOP MODEL!
SWIRL FOR THE TOP MODEL.
"ASWIRL" IS A MOVEMENT
IN THE GARMENTS.
LET'S PICK SOMETHING FOR YOU.
LOVE 'EM.
THEY'RE AWESOME.
LET'S HAVE MUSIC.
WE ARE GONNA DEMONSTRATE,
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
TEACH YOU HOW WE DO THE SWIRL.
♪ BABY ♪
♪ SWISH ♪
THAT'S THE SWIRL.
START IN THE BACK...
AND SWIRL.
♪♪♪
LESLIE WAS VERY TENSE,
AND SHE REMAINED THAT WAY
THROUGHOUT THE TECHNIQUE.
SWIRL, SWIRL, SWIRL.
SWIRL, SWIRL.
NOPE, NOPE, NOT LIKE THAT.
DON'T I LOOK WEIRD?
IT WAS KINDA DIFFICULT
AT FIRST, BECAUSE I THOUGHT
IT WAS A DANCE,
BUT I THINK I WAS DOIN'
A TWO-STEP OR AN ELECTRIC SLIDE.
I WAS NOT DOIN' ASWIRL.
♪♪♪
OH, YEAH.
- WHOO!
- MAKE THOSE GARMENTS--
THAT WRAP, THAT SCARF.
YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALL OVER THE PLACE ABOUT
BEAUTY
AND MODEL AND GARMENTS.
♪♪♪
(laughs)
I WANT TO BUY
- THAT GARMENT...
- WHOOPS!
AND I NEED YOU TO SWIRL
WITH BALANCE.
VERY DIFFICULT TO SWIRL IN,
AND VERY DIFFICULT
EVEN TO WALK IN A STRAIGHT LINE,
LET ALONE, YOU KNOW,
BE SWIRLIN' AROUND THE STAGE.
SARA--
ASWIRL WITH A STIFFNESS.
SARA ALSO WERE AFFECTED
BY HER HEIGHTH.
IT'S AN ATTITUDE.
GIVE ME ATTITUDE.
MAKE EYE CONTACT.
LET 'EM ALL KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
THE WHOLE ROOM--ATWIRL.
SWIRL.
HOW BEAUTIFUL.
WHEN YOU GO
TO THAT NEXT LEVEL, REMEMBER,
THE MOVEMENT,
THE FABRIC, THE SWIRL.
IT IS ABOUT ASWIRL.
THANKS, LADIES.
- IT WAS GORGEOUS.
- THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
NNENNA'S JUST GETTING OUT
RIGHT NOW, I THINK.
NNENNA'S STILL IN THERE?
YEP.
UNPLUG THE PHONE.
NNENNA BEEN ON THE PHONE
FOR AN HOUR.
SHE ON THE PHONE LIKE SHE'S
AT HER APARTMENT OR SOMETHIN'.
LIKE, YOU SEE THE SUN RISE,
YOU SEE IT SET,
YOU SEE THE EIFFEL TOWER,
YOU SEE THE CROWS CALL,
ALL THAT GO ON, AND NNENNA'S
STILL ON THE PHONE.
THERE IS OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE HOUSEHOLD WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TALK TO THEIR BOYFRIENDS.
HOLD ON.
NNENNA, HOW CAN YOU NOT
UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT
OF THE PHONE?
I DIDN'T SEE ANYBODY AROUND.
I LEFT THE DOOR WIDE OPEN,
- 'CAUSE--
- IT'S NOT VERY DIFFICULT,
AND YOU'RE A CHEMIST.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND ALL THAT,
BUT YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND
THE SIMPLE CONCEPT OF A PHONE?
I'M NOT AT ALL MOVED
BY BROOKE'S REACTION.
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
AND ALSO, ANOTHER THING
THAT HAS BOTHERED ME,
(dial tone)
YOU'VE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE...
(dialing telephone)
SHE IS A BITCH.
WHAT HAPPENED?
I'M, LIKE, I'VE HAD IT
UP TO HERE WITH NNENNA.
'CAUSE EVERYBODY THINKS
SHE'S SWEET,
EVERYBODY THINKS SHE IS NICE,
AND SHE IS NOT.
BROOKE?
THIS IS COMIN' OUT
OF BROOKE'S MOUTH?
NNENNA...
BROOKE IS MAD AT YOU, MAN.
SHE'S BACK THERE,
WHISPERING, LAUGHING AT ME.
WHAT MAKES HER SO MUCH BETTER
THAN ME?
SHE'S FROM AFRICA?
GO BACK TO AFRICA
IF IT'S SO DAMN GREAT.
I'VE NEVER SEEN BROOKE
- GO OFF LIKE THAT.
- SHE'S AN EMOTIONAL WRECK.
SHE CRIES EVERY DAY.
I DON'T CRY!
YOU ARE A...BITCH, NNENNA.
♪♪♪
OH, GOD.
I CANNOT BELIEVE
I JUST WENT OFF LIKE THAT.
YOU ARE A...
BITCH, NNENNA.
I CALLED NNENNA SOMETHING
THAT I SHOULDN'T HAVE,
AND I'M REALLY ASHAMED.
BROOKE, IF YOU'RE GONNA
GO OFF ON SOMEBODY,
DON'T MAKE
APOLOGIES FOR DOIN' IT.
YOU GOTTA GO FULL FORCE.
TYRA MAIL, TYRA MAIL!
LIAR!
TYRA MAIL!
NO, SERIOUSLY,
WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
READ IT, JUST READ IT.
"SASHAY, CHANTE."
YAY!
YOU'VE BEEN TO PARIS.
- WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
- SASHAY.
YOU SASHAY.
YOU WERE IN PARIS FOR...
WITH THE TWIRL AND THE PURSE
AND THE--OH, YEAH.
SASHAY, CHANTE.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE MY WALK DOWN.
I DEFINITELY DON'T HAVE
MY SIGNATURE WALK DOWN.
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
THEN WE DO A SWIRL, END.
LIKE, I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I'M STICKING MY BUTT OUT,
BUT I GUESS IT'S OUT.
LESLIE'S NOT A GOOD WALKER,
FLAT OUT.
SHE WAS THE DUCK BOOTY.
THAT'S THE GIRL WITH
THE DUCK BOOTY WALK.
I THINK YOU JUST HAVE
A LONGER BUTT.
I HAVE A SMALL, LITTLE BUTT.
I DON'T KNOW, I NEED TO WATCH,
LIKE, RUNWAY MORE, BECAUSE,
I STILL FEEL LIKE I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN HEARING
A LOT OF THE SAME STUFF
ABOUT OWNING MY HEIGHT,
BUT IT'S HARD,
BECAUSE I DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW TO PRACTICE THAT.
OH, THAT WAS CAKE...
HUH?
- THE WAY IT JUST CAME OFF.
- YEAH.
IT'S WEIRD, IT'S LIKE THERE'S A
BUNCH OF OTHER GIRLS HERE,
BUT I FEEL REALLY LONELY.
THAT FUNNY?
Sorry, baby.
So what'd you guys do today?
WE'RE DOING
RUNWAY STUFF AGAIN
THAT'S, LIKE,
EVEN MORE COMPLICATED NOW.
That's really decent stuff.
You can really sell that.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN
SLOUCHING SO MUCH MORE.
I'M HERE WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO GET INTO MODELING FOR YEARS,
AND I WAS FOUND IN A MALL.
THAT JUST MAKES ME WANNA
SHOW THEM THAT
I REALLY WANNA BE HERE
AND THAT I DESERVE IT.
Well, it's probably
gonna get more stressful.
DEFINITELY,
I'M JUST--YEAH.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL SAYS,
"SASHAY, CHANTE."
I THOUGHT OF RuPAUL.
WASN'T THAT, LIKE, HIS PHRASE?
OKAY, WE'RE GONNA BE DOING DRAG?
(Handel's "Messiah"
playing on organ)
WHAT CAN WE POSSIBLY
BE DOING IN A CHURCH?
BUT, OF COURSE, I BLESSED MYSELF
WITH THE HOLY WATER--
DIP, DIP, DIP, DIP, DIP.
DAD'S A PREACHER--
RAISED IN THE CHURCH.
WHEN I WAS IN THE WOMB,
I'VE NEVER MISSED A SUNDAY,
LET'S JUST PUT IT THAT WAY.
HELLO, LADIES.
MY NAME IS ROY CAMPBELL,
AND I'M A PRODUCER
OF SPECIAL EVENTS
AND FASHION SHOWS.
I ALSO HAVE DONE EVENTS
FOR TYRA BANKS
WHO'S A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
I FIRST MET TYRA
AFTER SHE DEBUTED IN PARIS
DURING HER FIRST SEASON.
NOW IF YOU'RE WONDERING
WHY YOU'RE HERE IN THE CHURCH,
YESTERDAY, MISS J.
TAUGHT YOU
HOW TO REMOVE GARMENTS
ON THE RUNWAY,
AND THE TWINS SHOWED YOU
HOW TO SWIRL AND TWIRL.
TODAY YOU'RE GONNA BE TESTED
- IN A CHURCH FASHION SHOW.
- ♪ HALLELUJAH ♪
OKAY.
- ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO
WITH RUNWAY, I DON'T CARE
IF IT'S IN THE SAHARA DESERT.
IF THERE'S A RUNWAY,
JADE IS GONNA BE ON IT.
IN THE EARLY '40s,
BLACKS COULD NOT
GO TO FASHION SHOWS.
THEY HAD TO PRESENT
THEIR OWN FASHION SHOWS.
CHURCH FASHION SHOWS
ARE A BIG TRADITION
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
FOR TODAY'S TEST,
WE EXPECT YOU TO SASHAY, SWIRL,
TWIRL, AND MAKE THOSE CLOTHES
COME ALIVE,
AND WE INVITED
THE WHOLE CONGREGATION
OF THIS CHURCH TO WATCH YOU
WORK THOSE GARMENTS.
I WAS NERVOUS.
I HAVE SO MUCH TROUBLE ALREADY
WALKING NORMALLY.
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO SWIRL
AND BE DRAMATIC?
AND TODAY'S JUDGES
ARE TWO DESIGNERS
YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH--
WORLD-RENOWNED DESIGNER
LLOYD KLEIN.
- HELLO, LLOYD, WELCOME.
- HELLO, HOW ARE YOU?
- I'M GOOD.
- HELLO, HELLO, HELLO.
I'M SO HAPPY TO MEET YOU.
AND WE HAVE
DIAMOND DESIGNER SOL RAFAEL.
(applause)
HI, LADIES.
LLOYD AND I, WE GONNA CHOOSE
ONE WINNER WHO WE FEEL
HAS THE BEST BODY MOVEMENT
ON THE RUNWAY,
AND THAT GIRL IS GONNA BE
GETTING A HUGE PRIZE OF
$25,000 DIAMOND RING.
WOW.
SHOW THOSE CLOTHES OFF
AND WIN THAT PRIZE.
DANG.
EVERYBODY IS SO CRYING,
THEY'RE LIKE, "DIAMONDS?
DIAMONDS?"
♪♪♪
OKAY, EVERYONE.
FIRST LOOK NOW.
THE SHOW IS GONNA START.
I LOVE THIS COLOR.
I WAS SCARED
BEFORE I CAME HERE,
JUST BECAUSE
I NEVER WEAR HIGH HEELS.
LIKE, I WAS SCARED
OF HIGH HEELS
BECAUSE I'M JUST LIKE,
I'M GONNA FALL ON MY BUTT.
GORGEOUS DRESSES,
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
REALLY ASWIRL AROUND
AND REALLY SHOW OFF
A LOT OF FABRIC.
♪♪♪
GET READY
TO SHOUT "HALLELUJAH"
AND TO SCREAM "AMEN."
(cheering)
TALK ABOUT MAKING
A DRAMATIC ENTRANCE...
DANIELLE
NEEDS MORE PERSONALITY
ON THE RUNWAY, DEFINITELY.
BUT AS MY MAMA USED TO SAY,
"YOU AIN'T SEEN NOTHIN' YET."
(cheering)
YOU WALK OUT THERE,
AND THE ENERGY WAS JUST GREAT.
WORK IT, WORK IT.
I PULLED OUT OF MY MIND,
"NOW WALK STRAIGHT."
I WAS LIKE,
"I'M WORKIN' MY HIPS,
AND IF MISS J.
DOESN'T LIKE THAT, TOO BAD."
THE DRESSES I WAS WEARING
WAS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR MYSELF TO WALK IN.
SO I WAS REALLY WORRIED THAT
I WAS GONNA END UP TRIPPING.
DON'T BE SHY.
YOU'RE ON THE CATWALK NOW.
THAT'S IT, SWIRL AND TWIRL.
BROOKE NEEDS TO WORK
ON HER PRESENCE.
SHE'S A LITTLE BIT ABSENT.
OH, SASHAY DOWN THE RUNWAY.
COME ON, THAT'S IT,
PUT SOME PEP IN YOUR STEP.
I LIKE IT A LOT.
(laughs)
THAT RUNWAY IS SUPER GREAT.
MY ENERGY LEVEL WAS UP.
JADE AND I CAN
REALLY COMPETE NOW,
BECAUSE THAT'S ULTIMATELY
WHO I THINK IT'S BETWEEN.
(shouting)
SOMEBODY SAY "HALLELUJAH."
YOU GOT TO BREAK IT ON DOWN!
YOU GOT TO GIVE IT UP.
(cheering)
SWIRL AND TWIRL.
BREAK IT ON DOWN.
- THAT A GIRL.
- I WOULD TAKE TWO STEPS
AND I WOULD STEP ON THE TRAIN.
I DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE IN IT,
AND I'M SURE THAT SHOWED.
YEAH!
WHOO!
♪♪♪
THAT'S RIGHT, AMEN TO THAT.
THAT IS WONDERFUL!
ONE OF THE DRESSERS SAID
I HAD ONE
OF THE HOTTEST LOOKS TODAY,
AND I'M DEFINITELY
GONNA WORK IT.
I'M GONNA WORK IT OUT FOR GOD.
♪♪♪
I WAS TWIRLIN' MY BUTT OFF,
AND I'M THINKIN',
"JADE, JUST PULL THIS OFF."
TWIRL, TWIRL!
JADE CAME OUT,
AND SHE JUST STARTED TURNING
AND TWIRLING AND TWIRLING.
THAT'S WHAT A COMMUNITY
FASHION SHOW IS ALL ABOUT.
WE HAVE THE BEST ENERGY.
I THINK I DID SHOW JADE UP.
SO I THINK
I DEFINITELY WON THAT ONE.
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING
TO SEE, UH, ALL OF YOU.
I THINK SOL AND I
CHOSE A WINNER FOR THE BEST WAY
YOU SHOWED THE CLOTHES
AND THE JEWELRY,
AND THE WINNER...
IS...
JADE.
OH, YES!
WHOO!
HEY, LOOK AT THIS GIRL!
I WAS WORKING IT.
I SHOULD HAVE WON.
I'M SO MAD.
AAH!
JADE WAS TRIPPIN'.
I MEAN, I FEEL HER, 'CAUSE
IT'S DIAMONDS YOU WINNIN',
BUT CHILL OUT.
YOU HAVE $25,000
DIAMOND RING.
♪♪♪
I GOT A LITTLE BONUS FOR YOU.
I WANT YOU TO PICK
ONE OF YOUR FRIENDS,
AND WE'RE GONNA GIVE HER
A $10,000 DIAMOND RING
AS WELL.
FURONDA.
WE GOT ANOTHER BONUS FOR YOU.
OKAY.
WE WANT YOU TO PICK
ANOTHER FRIEND OF YOURS,
AND WE'RE GONNA GIVE HER
$8,000 DIAMOND RING.
NNENNA.
(laughs)
I NEVER EXPECTED
TO BE PICKED BY JADE.
I'M NOT DISAPPOINTED
THAT I DIDN'T GET PICKED BY HER.
I'M DISAPPOINTED
THAT I DIDN'T EARN IT MYSELF.
THANK YOU.
I WISH
I WOULD HAVE DONE BETTER.
♪♪♪
WHAT?
YES, THANK YOU, JESUS.
JADE HAS WON TWO CHALLENGES.
FURONDA, YOU GOT ONE.
I GOT ONE.
- GOT ONE UNDER MY BELT.
- I HAVE ZERO.
I'M SO COOL.
HOW MANY HAVE YOU--
YOU--WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE
STANDIN' THERE WAITIN'
FOR THE WINNER TO BE SAID?
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"I DON'T WANT JADE TO WIN."
I'M HERE TO DO WELL,
NOT TO GET INVOLVED
IN THOSE LITTLE THINGS,
BUT I DON'T LIKE NNENNA,
AND JUST BECAUSE
I HANDLE MY STRESS
IN DIFFERENT WAYS THAN OTHERS
DOESN'T MAKE ME A CRYBABY.
♪♪♪
HEY, DADDY.
You okay?
YEAH.
(crying)
I JUST HATE IT HERE SO MUCH.
I don't wanna
hear you worrying too much.
WELL, BECAUSE I SAID
SOMETHING I SHOULDN'T HAVE,
'CAUSE, DAD, I CALLED HER
A NAME, AND I FEEL SO BAD.
IT'S NOT REALLY LIKE ME
TO BE LIKE THAT.
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH
OTHER PRESSURES
TO, LIKE, DEAL WITH,
AND THEN THAT ADDED TO IT
AND JUST BEING FRUSTRATED,
AND THEN, YOU KNOW...
I'm sure
it's very stressful.
I'm sure they push you hard.
RIGHT, AND SO THAT'S, LIKE,
I DO WANNA STICK IT OUT.
- LIKE, I DON'T WANNA--
- Sure.
BE JUST LIKE,
"OKAY, I GIVE UP."
I'M GONNA TRY.
Give 'em heck.
OKAY, DADDY.
I LOVE YOU VERY MUCH,
AND IT WAS GOOD TALKING TO YOU.
♪♪♪
I CAN'T IMAGINE GOING BACK
HOME AND JUST...
DOING MY
EVERYDAY MUNDANE LIFE.
LIVING IN ARIZONA, NOT EXACTLY
THE CAPITAL--
FASHION CAPITAL.
BUT AFTER EXPERIENCING
ALL THAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED HERE, I CAN'T
JUST SETTLE FOR THAT.
I CAN'T SETTLE.
TYRA MAIL!
OH, MY GOD!
WE'RE GONNA DANCE.
"SOMETIMES ON THE MORNING
OF AN IMPORTANT JOB,
I USED TO GET
REALLY BAD STOMACH KRUMPS,
BUT I STILL GOT OFF MY BUTT
AND WORKED IT.
- TYRA."
- CRUMPETS?
WAIT, DID SHE SAY SOMETIMES
SHE GETS STOMACH CRAMPS?
"STOMACH KRUMPS."
LOOK AT THAT
LITTLE TEENY BUTT.
♪♪♪
WHY Y'ALL LOOK SO TIRED?
IT'S A GREAT MORNING
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO DO
A REALLY COOL SHOOT
FOR PAYLESS SHOES.
PAYLESS SHOES
ARE NOT ONLY AFFORDABLE,
THEY'RE REALLY HIP,
AND ACTUALLY,
PAYLESS STYLES
ARE SO FASHION-FORWARD,
THAT THEY'VE MADE THEIR DEBUT
IN NEW YORK'S FASHION WEEK
THIS PAST SEPTEMBER,
AND THE PAYLESS SHOES
YOU GIRLS ARE WEARING TODAY
ARE INSPIRED BY
THE FASHION RUNWAY.
SO IF WE'RE DOING SHOES,
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE'RE DOIN'?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
ON TOP OF A ROOF,
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WE'RE LEAPIN' FROM THE BUILDING.
WE GOTTA DO A LITTLE DANCING,
'CAUSE YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
LEARNING ABOUT MOVEMENT.
SO GUESS WHAT, GIRL?
WE HAVE TOMMY THE CLOWN
AND HIS KRUMPERS HERE TODAY.
TOMMY!
(cheering)
HEY, LADIES!
KRUMPING IS A HIGH-ENERGY
STYLE OF HIP-HOP DANCE,
KIND OF REMINISCENT
OF BREAK DANCING.
AND TOMMY AND HIS KRUMPERS--
THEY'RE GOING
TO BE IN YOUR SHOT
AND TEACH YOU GIRLS HOW TO MOVE.
HEY!
(speaking indistinctly)
GO!
(cheering)
DANCING IS LIKE A FULFILLMENT
TO THE SOUL FOR ME.
JADE CAN DANCE.
SO TO CAPTURE
THIS WHOLE SCENE,
I HAD TO GET A REALLY COOL
EDITORIAL PHOTOGRAPHER
TO GIVE IT A LITTLE URBAN EDGE.
HIS NAME IS TREVOR--
TREVOR, COME ON OUT HERE.
HOW YOU DOING?
SO I NEED YOU TO BRING
TOMMY'S ENERGY TO THE PICTURES.
SO REMEMBER THE ENERGY
AND SHOW OFF
THOSE PAYLESS SHOES.
COOL, LET'S GO.
I JUST NEED TO STEP IT UP.
I THINK I DEFINITELY NEED
TO STEP IT UP.
BUT I USED TO DANCE,
SO I KNOW I CAN GET A GOOD SHOT.
♪♪♪
SO WHAT KIND OF DANCE
CLASSES HAVE YOU TAKEN?
WELL, I TOOK BALLET
WHEN I WAS REALLY YOUNG.
I CAN DEFINITELY DANCE.
YOU CAN DANCE?
(laughing)
SO THE WHITE GIRL CAN DANCE?
ALL RIGHT, WE GOTTA SEE THIS.
SHE SAYS SHE CAN DANCE, Y'ALL.
AND THEN MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE, YOU KNOW, FUNKY.
YOU LOOK REAL URBAN.
COOL.
HEY, JOANIE.
SO, YOU READY TO DO THIS?
ALL RIGHT,
NOTICE THE CAMERA'S REAL LOW.
THAT'S SO THAT YOUR LEGS LOOK
REALLY, REALLY LONG AND REALLY
FOCUS ON THE SHOES,
'CAUSE
THE SHOES LOOK REALLY COOL.
MAKE SURE YOU AT LEAST
EXTEND THAT LEG FORWARD.
- OKAY.
- 'CAUSE IF YOU EXTEND
IT FORWARD,
IT MAKES THE LEG LOOK
- REALLY, REALLY, REALLY LONG,
- OKAY.
AND IT ALSO BRINGS FOCUS
TO THE BOOT.
WHOO!
♪♪♪
- WHOO!
- NOW PUT YOUR HANDS
ON YOUR HEAD.
♪♪♪
MY ONLY NEGATIVE
WITH JOANIE IS,
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE
AS SHE WAS DANCING,
SHE WOULD GET THAT
MEAN MUGGIN' FACE ON, LIKE...
♪♪♪
MISS FURONDA,
IF YOU DO NOT BRING IT,
YOUR BLACK SISTERS ARE GONNA
SHAME YOU IN THE STREETS.
(laughing)
IN THE STREETS?
YOU NEED TO--
CAN YOU DANCE AT LEAST?
YES, YEAH, I CAN DANCE.
I NEED YOU TO GET INTO THIS.
IF YOU DON'T GET INTO THIS,
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
ENERGY, ENERGY.
FURONDA.
YOU THINK YOU'RE A DANCER?
WHOO!
OH, I DIDN'T...
WHOO! WHOO!
FURONDA, YOU'RE BEING A
LITTLE OF A LIMP RAG DOLL.
CAN'T YOU GIVE ME A
LITTLE MORE?
JUST A LITTLE MORE "UNH!"
SHOW OFF THAT PAYLESS BOOT!
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT,
GETTING YOUR PAYLESS SHOE ON.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO FREAK OUT.
I KNOW IT'S A COMPETITION.
I KNOW THERE'S THAT STRESS...
- RIGHT.
- GOING ON, BUT YOU CAN'T...
- LET IT AFFECT ME.
- YOU CAN'T LET YOUR
NERVES CONSUME YOU.
BROOKE HAS BEEN LETTING
A LOT OF THINGS
BUILD UP ON HER--AND THIS
SITUATION WITH NNENNA,
BROOKE IS REALLY
LOSING IT RIGHT NOW.
I KINDA FREEZE UP SOMETIMES
WHEN, LIKE,
I PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON MYSELF TO PERFORM.
AND WHEN I DO THAT,
I KINDA FREEZE.
WHOO!
OKAY, PLEASE DO THE
BLACK GIRLS PROUD.
WELL, YOU KNOW, THEY CALL ME
A WHITE GIRL BACK HOME, BUT...
SO YOU CAN'T DANCE?
I'M-A DO--I'M-A DO
- WHAT I DO.
- WAIT, CAN YOU DANCE?
I MEAN, I'M-A DO WHAT I DO.
OKAY, IF YOU'RE A WHITE GIRL,
THINK IRENE CARA.
FEEL FREE TO, LIKE,
STOMP AND, LIKE, HIT IT,
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
TO FEATURE THE SHOES.
THEY LOOK COOL, THEY LOOK HIP.
YOU'RE KRUMPING.
YEP!
DANIELLE, STOMP THAT WATER!
YEAH, DON'T COVER YOUR FACE.
STOMP IT AGAIN.
SHAKE IT, SHAKE IT,
SHIMMY, SHIMMY.
GREAT.
THERE YOU GO.
DANIELLE, LET'S SEE THAT SHOE!
THERE YOU GO,
SLAM IN THAT SHOE.
DANIELLE,
YOU WERE LYING TO ME.
YOU WERE LIKE,
"I-I-I JUST GOT A LITTLE
WHITE GIRL THING IN ME."
♪♪♪
SO, SARA,
KEEP YOUR CHIN DOWN,
AND YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
SHOWING OFF YOUR SHOE.
HEY, SARA,
JUST WATCH YOUR MOUTH.
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THIS THING
WITH THE LEG UP,
IT'S CUTE, BUT THIS
IS WHAT YOU'RE DOING--
YOU'RE DOING THIS,
YOU'RE GOING...
LIKE, THE MOUTH IS JUST...
I DEFINITELY WAS CONSCIOUS
OF MY HEIGHT
AND JUST TRYING TO, YOU KNOW,
GET THE RIGHT ANGLES,
AND I'M HOPING THAT
JAY'S HAPPY WITH IT, SO...
(train whistle blows)
♪♪♪
HEY, NNENNA, LOOK AT ME,
LOOK AT ME, LOOK AT ME!
THERE YOU GO,
THAT'S GREAT.
NNENNA,
I WANNA SEE SOME OF THAT
AFRICAN STUFF.
AND IT'S KRUMPING,
SO I NEED TO SEE A LITTLE...
OKAY.
THERE YOU GO, DANCING AROUND!
NNENNA GOT OUT THERE,
AND SHE WAS A BIT TOUGH
TO BRING THE
ENERGY OUT OF HER.
NNENNA, I WANT YOU
TO DANCE, THOUGH,
LET'S JUST GET IT
TO REALLY DANCE.
DON'T POSE.
THIS WAS NNENNA
THE WHOLE TIME...
"AM I PRETTY?
AM I PRETTY?"
- HEY!
- HEY, HOW YOU DOING?
WHAT'S UP?
I KNOW I CAN MOVE MY BODY.
I KNOW I CAN BE GRACEFUL.
LONG AS I FORGET ABOUT
MY NERVES AND, YOU KNOW,
AND JUST BREATHE,
I'LL BE GOOD.
COME A LITTLE CLOSER, LESLIE.
THERE YOU GO.
LOOK AT THE CAMERA, LESLIE.
ONE MORE,
ONE, TWO, THREE.
MY ONLY THING, LESLIE,
IS YOU'RE GIVING ME TWO MOVES.
'CAUSE YOU'RE GIVING ME
THE SAME KIND OF, "WHOO!"
YOU KNOW?
LESLIE!
WORK IT LESLIE,
COME ON!
IS THAT HOW YOU DANCE
FOR THE MEN?
(chuckling)
I DON'T...
- I DON'T DANCE.
- NO, I WANT YOU TO BE
IN THE CLUB, WORKING IT,
BECAUSE YOU WANNA
GET A LITTLE SOMETHING.
THERE YOU GO!
RIGHT AT MY CAMERA, LESLIE.
ONE MORE,
ONE, TWO, THREE!
I THINK
I WAS THINKING TOO MUCH.
I WAS POSING MORE
THAN I WAS JUST DANCING.
I WAS THINKING,
"I WANNA GET A GOOD SHOT."
I WASN'T LETTING GO.
♪♪♪
WELL, I SHOULD'VE DONE, LIKE,
REALLY GOOD.
I KNOW I CAN DANCE.
I MEAN, I'M NOT THE BEST DANCER,
BUT I'M NOT...
HORRIBLE.
I'M ALWAYS LIKE,
"CAN I GET A REDO?
CAN YOU SHOOT ME,
YOU KNOW, ONE MORE TIME?"
- BROOKE.
- BROOKE!
DON'T LOOK NERVOUS.
OH, MY GOD, DON'T START CRYING.
HONEY,
I ALREADY FEEL THE NERVES.
BREATHE, BREATHE.
THESE GUYS
HAVE LOTS OF ENERGY.
FEED OFF IT.
GO WITH IT.
THIS IS BROOKE, Y'ALL.
HEY, BROOKE!
YO, CAN I GET, "BROOKE"?
BROOKE!
OH, YOU HAVE GREAT LEGS.
THERE YOU GO.
THERE YOU GO!
TURN IT FLAT TO THE CAMERA
SO I SEE THE DETAIL
ON THE SHOES.
BROOKE HAS A KILLER BODY,
BUT I THINK SHE WENT OFF
INTO THOSE STRIPPER POSES.
♪♪♪
BE HAPPY ABOUT YOUR SHOES.
THERE, YOU'RE HAPPY ABOUT
THOSE PAYLESS SHOES.
TEN FRAMES, GUYS.
LET'S GET HER
A BOTTLE OF WATER.
♪♪♪
I WON THE CHALLENGE
OF THE DAY,
AND MY SPIRITS ARE UP.
I FEEL SO GOOD,
BECAUSE THIS IS, LIKE,
MY GEN-DRE OF A PHOTO SHOOT.
THERE YOU GO.
GO, JADE!
THERE YOU GO!
HEY!
WHOO!
IT'S GREAT,
IT'S GREAT ENERGY.
JUST SLOW IT DOWN
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
COME EVEN CLOSER.
THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE IMPRESSED ME.
LOOK AT ME.
I AM A SUPERMODEL.
DO YOU SEE THE POTENTIAL?
DO YOU SEE IT?
THERE YOU GO.
WHOO!
OH, OH, OH, OH, OH!
- MOVE IT, JADE!
- THERE YOU GO!
JADE PICKED UP
THE WATER BOTTLE AT THE END,
THREW THE WATER
OFF HER CHEST, AND PSHHH!
IT WAS SO CLASSIC TYRA,
DOING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
JUST TO MAKE THE SHOT
EXTRA-SPECIAL.
♪♪♪
♪ JOANIE AND DANIELLE ♪
♪ GO WAY BACK ♪
♪ I LOOK GREAT AND I SHINE ♪
♪ ON "TOP MODEL" ♪
♪ YOU WANNA BE LIKE ME? ♪
♪ ME AND JOANIE ♪
♪ DO IT SO TOUGH ♪
TYRA MAIL!
♪ I'M SO TOUGH ♪
♪ I'M-A PASS MY FLOW TO JO-JO ♪
(laughs)
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SEVEN WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I'M A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS.
I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, THERE'S JUST
NOT A WHOLE LOT
I CAN DO ABOUT IT
AT THIS POINT,
SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO STAY CALM AND...
♪♪♪
EXCUSE ME, NNENNA.
I LET MY NERVES
GET THE BETTER OF ME,
AND I KINDA WANNA
PROVE TO TYRA
THAT I CAN BE A MODEL.
I'M WONDERING HOW, LIKE,
SARA DID, YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE SHE'S REALLY TALL
AND THEY'RE ALL SO SHORT.
I'M WONDERING HOW THAT LOOKED.
I'M NOT REALLY CONFIDENT
ABOUT MY PHOTO SHOOT.
I THINK I COULD'VE
DONE A LOT BETTER,
AND I'M THINKING
THAT IT'S PROBABLY ME
THAT'S GONNA GO HOME.
♪♪♪
HELLO, EVERYBODY.
YOU LOOK VERY NICE.
BUT TODAY IT'S TIME
TO MAKE ANOTHER CUT.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE GOING HOME.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THESE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY A WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
FROM COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
WE KNOW THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR.
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
AND, OF COURSE,
HE IS YOUR RUNWAY COACH.
AND FASHION ICON TWIGGY.
HELLO, YOU ALL
LOOK GORGEOUS.
AND ROY CAMPBELL
IS A FASHION JOURNALIST
AND CELEBRITY FASHION EVENT
PRODUCER.
I'VE KNOWN ROY
SINCE I WAS 17 YEARS OLD.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
- BACK IN THE DAY IN PARIS,
AND I THINK HE WROTE
THE VERY FIRST ARTICLE
ABOUT ME IN FASHION.
ALL RIGHTY,
SO THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR A MODEL
TO KNOW HOW TO MOVE.
YOU HAD A SOULFUL WEEK
WORKING WITH MISS J.,
THE TWINS, AND DOING
A CHURCH RUNWAY FASHION SHOW.
THAT'S THE VERY FIRST
FASHION SHOW THAT I EVER SAW.
AND I WAS LIKE,
"WOW, THIS IS THEATRICAL.
THIS IS AMAZING."
(cheers and applause)
SO WHEN PEOPLE SEE ME
DOING ALL THAT
AND KINDA SASHAYING
AND LOOKING
TO THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT...
I WAS USING LITTLE BITS OF THAT,
AND I MADE IT MY OWN.
SO TODAY YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
THE CHURCH FASHION SHOW WALK
BUT INCORPORATE IT INTO YOU.
IF YOU'RE
WALKING IN SILHOUETTE,
THE RUNWAY IS PITCH-BLACK
AND YOU'RE WALKING DOWN
THAT RUNWAY, THEY KNOW.
"OOH, THAT'S HER,
I CAN TELL.
BECAUSE THAT'S A SIGNATURE WALK
AND IT MAKES HER SPECIAL."
BUT THERE'S A LITTLE ADDED TWIST
TO THIS--
THIS IS WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO...
ALL RIGHTY.
SIGNATURE WALK, SIGNATURE
WALK, SIGNATURE WALK.
♪♪♪
THAT'S MY SIGNATURE WALK.
THEN I WANT YOU
TO GET BACK HERE,
HIT THIS,
AND...
TURN,
AS IF YOU ARE ON A TURNTABLE.
DO YOU SEE HOW SMOOTH THAT IS?
BRILLIANT!
(chuckles)
(applause)
SO WHAT I'M CHECKING FOR
IS YOUR POSTURE
AND YOUR BALANCE.
ALL RIGHTY,
LET'S GET STARTED.
MISS JADE, YOU'RE FIRST TODAY.
♪♪♪
THANKS, SARA.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
FIRST IS JADE.
YOU WERE A BIT STUCK
ON THE TURN.
YOU MANAGED, BUT YOU WERE A
LITTLE BIT STUCK,
LIKE YOU WERE TURNING IN GRAVEL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD WALK.
BUT A GREAT WALK
WOULD BE YOU GIVING
A LITTLE BIT MORE POWER,
'CAUSE YOU'RE JUST LIKE THIS.
I WANNA SEE...
(exhales deeply)
ALTHOUGH,
AT THE CHURCH FASHION SHOW,
YOU WON THE CHALLENGE,
MISS JADE.
(applause)
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO KRUMP.
DOES EVERYBODY KNOW
WHAT KRUMPING IS?
- TWIGGY?
- I DON'T.
WELL, KRUMPING IS--
IT'S A NEW TYPE OF DANCING
THAT'S TAKING OVER BY STORM.
IT'S JUST CRAZY MOVEMENT.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO IT.
♪ GO, TYRA ♪
♪ GO, J. ♪
(laughing)
KRUMPING!
- NOW, MISS TWIGGY...
- NOT REALLY!
I-I'M GONNA STICK
TO TAP DANCING, THANK YOU.
(laughs)
JADE, HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
♪♪♪
SHE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
SHE'S KRUMPING TO ME.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S HUMPING.
YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M LOOKING AT YOU,
DESPITE THE CLOWN
IN THE BACKGROUND.
BUT YOU DID FORGET
YOU WERE MODELING.
YOUR FACE WAS STRONG,
BUT YOU HAD ALL THIS, "UH, UH!"
BUT YOU WERE LIKE,
"OH! AH! UH! OH!"
EVERYTHING WAS GREAT
EXCEPT THIS.
NEXT IS SARA.
YOU'RE LIKE A TANK
COMING DOWN THAT RUNWAY AT US.
BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM, BAM!
ALL RIGHTY, SARA,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
QUITE INTERESTING, ACTUALLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S--
IS THAT "KLUMPING"?
KRUMPING.
KRUMPING!
(laughs)
I MEAN, AT THE BAT OF AN EYE,
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU'RE SLIPPING
ON A BANANA PEEL.
I WAS TRYING
TO SHOW OFF THE SHOES.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
SHOWING OFF PAYLESS SHOES.
IT'S DEFINITELY
A SHOE SHOT, TOO.
EXACTLY--I MEAN,
THIS CAN'T BE
ABOUT NAILING
KRUMPING PROPERLY.
IT'S GOTTA BE ABOUT
PRODUCING A GREAT SHOT.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER,
THIS IS THE MONEY RIGHT HERE.
UP NEXT IS FURONDA.
FURONDA--GUYS, YOU
THINK I COULD TAKE HER
TO THE DOCTOR
AND BREAK HER RIGHT ARM?
THAT'S PARALYZED?
I'VE GOTTA SAY THAT
YOU DO HAVE
- A SIGNATURE WALK.
- I AGREE.
WHETHER ONE LIKES IT OR NOT,
- IT IS A SIGNATURE.
- I AGREE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW.
THE FACE IS SLAMMING.
AND YOU'RE REALLY CONNECTING
WITH THE CAMERA,
SO WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT, FURONDA.
NEXT IS BROOKE.
BROOKE, I LOVE YOU, BUT
THAT WAS JUST
A DREADFUL WALK.
I TOTALLY DISAGREE.
UM, I LOVED YOUR WALK.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SEXY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS CHIC.
ALL RIGHTY, BROOKE,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE THE FACE.
(chuckles)
THE FACE LOOKS LIKE
YOUR NAME IS "LaBROOKE."
IT--IT'S VERY ETHNIC AND SEXY.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT LOOK
FOR YOU.
IT'S VERY RAUNCHY.
(laughter)
I LIKE IT, IT'S GOOD.
BROOKE,
THIS IS THE REAL DEAL.
THAT FIERCENESS...
THEN I THINK YOU WOULD OWN IT.
THEN IT WOULD BE A SIGNATURE
ON THE RUNWAY.
THERE'S NOTHING SIGNATURE
ABOUT CONFUSION.
NEXT UP IS JOANIE.
YOU TOTALLY DID IT.
THAT WALK THAT YOU HAD TODAY
WAS SO SOULFUL,
BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IT WAS YOU.
AND I SAW SOME SIGNATURE.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
WELL, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO KRUMP.
UH-OH, WORK IT OUT.
DO US A--DO A
LITTLE SOMETHING.
(laughter)
YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
OH, YOUR FATHER'S GONNA
GET YOU.
(laughter)
OR GET US.
OKAY, UH, HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
♪♪♪
- WHOA!
- WOW!
INCREDIBLE.
I LOVE THE ANIMATION.
- I LOVE THAT.
- YEAH, THAT POPS.
UP NEXT IS DANIELLE.
DANIELLE, I THOUGHT
YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL WALK.
- THANK YOU.
- VERY SIMPLE, BUT YOU OWN IT.
IT'S A GOOD WALK,
BUT BY NO MEANS
IS IT A SIGNATURE WALK.
IN SILHOUETTE,
I WOULDN'T KNOW WHO THAT WAS.
IT JUST MAKES YOU LOOK
COMPETENT,
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE YOU LOOK
AMAZING.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE LIGHT ON YOUR FACE
IS, WELL, BEAUTIFUL.
(growling)
I THINK IT'S GOOD,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GREAT.
LIKE, YOU GO CLOSE AND, YEAH,
IT'S PRETTY AND IT'S SAUCY,
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE THAT,
"UH, UH."
ALL RIGHT, MISS NNENNA.
SO, NNENNA, UM, YOUR TURN,
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"HOW COULD YOU MAKE A FULL TURN
BY HOW YOU PLACED YOUR FEET?"
YOU DID A HALF-TURN
AND WENT BACK THE SAME WAY.
YEAH, THE OLD BACK-AND-FORTH.
TYRA DEMONSTRATES
SOMETHING, PAY ATTENTION.
DON'T JUST GO, "OH, SO OKAY,
I'M-A DO THIS."
SO YOU HAVE A GENERAL IDEA
OF WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
ALL RIGHTY, NNENNA,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
(mumbles)
OH, NNENNA, THAT'S PRETTY.
NNENNA AND THE BOYS AGAIN.
(laughter)
BUT LOOK AT THAT,
LOOK AT THAT.
THAT IS YOUR MONEY SHOT.
THAT SMILE--YOU ARE RELAXED,
COMFORTABLE.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
FROM THAT.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE LESLIE.
♪♪♪
THAT TURN,
THAT TURN...
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
THAT WAS PRETTY DREADFUL.
AND YOU'VE GOT A GREAT BODY,
BUT YOU'RE NOT SHOWING IT
TO ITS BEST ADVANTAGE.
YOU NEED TO DO THE TURTLE
MORE WHEN YOU WALK.
MEANING, YOU HAVE
TO STICK YOUR NECK OUT.
'CAUSE, NATURALLY,
YOU STAND LIKE THIS,
AND YOUR NECK IS PUSHED BACK.
YEAH, DO IT RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT THAT--
IT PROBABLY FEELS CRAZY,
BUT IT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE A KRUMPER.
TO KRUMP OR NOT TO KRUMP?
OR TO SALSA?
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYONE KRUMP
IN ME LIFE.
IT IS A NEW
WORD TO ME, BUT, UM,
IT'S A GOOD FASHION SHOT.
THE ENERGY THAT
YOU ARE PORTRAYING HERE IS NOT
WHAT THE OTHER GIRLS
WERE GIVING.
- RIGHT.
- IT'S TOO MUCH LIKE,
"LOOK AT ME,
I'M BEING PRETTY."
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THESE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
SO WHO IS GOING HOME?
JOANIE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST SHOTS
I'VE EVER SEEN OF JOANIE.
I THINK
THIS IS WHO JOANIE IS.
- MM-HMM.
- I THINK THIS IS WHO
JOANIE IS WITH HER FRIENDS.
I THINK THIS IS WHO
SHE IS IN HER HOMETOWN.
BUT WHEN YOU WATCH HER,
SHE SEEMS RELUCTANT TO SMILE,
'CAUSE I THINK HER TEETH
NEED SOME WORK.
- MM-HMM.
- BUT SHE MANAGED
TO KICK UP HER HEELS.
LESLIE.
SHE'S PHOTOGENIC,
THE CAMERA LOVES HER.
YEAH, NO DOUBT THE GIRL
CAN TAKE GOOD PICTURES.
BUT I AM NOT CONVINCED
WITH LESLIE IN PERSON.
BUT I DO THINK
SHE'S GOT SOMETHING.
I'D JUST LIKE TO KEEP HER IN
TO KEEP AN EYE ON HER.
SHE COULD BE A FABULOUS
PRINT MODEL,
BUT TOP MODEL'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT,
AND I REALLY DON'T SEE HER
AS BEING 3-D AT ALL.
NNENNA.
PAYLESS SHOES,
THEY LOOK PHENOMENAL.
SHE'S SELLING THE SHOES.
- NNENNA, NNENNA.
UM, NNENNA TO ME
HAS GOT A UNIQUENESS.
MY WORRY WITH HER IS THIS
KIND OF SLIGHT BLANDNESS.
DANIELLE.
THE PICTURE'S NOT
ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I STILL LOVE THIS GIRL.
DANIELLE'S BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE'S ALMOST TOO NATURAL.
I WISH SHE'D PUT ON
A LITTLE MASCARA...
- AND LIP GLOSS.
- A LITTLE BLUSH.
- MOISTURIZER.
- IT'LL WAKE HER--
MOISTURIZER,
SHE LOOKS KINDA ASHY.
FURONDA.
SHE'S GIVING YOU
THIS SORT OF GHETTO DIVA.
I LIKE FURONDA
'CAUSE SHE'S DIFFERENT.
FURONDA LOOKS LIKE FURONDA.
I THINK FURONDA SHOULD STAY.
I JUST WANNA
FIX HER RIGHT ARM.
JADE.
HERE SHE PUTS HER BEST FOOT
FORWARD.
DOES SHE SCARE YOU AT ALL?
NO, NOT AT ALL.
SHE CAN PHOTOGRAPH
A LITTLE TOO OLD,
BUT SHE'S ALMOST GETTING YOUNGER
RIGHT IN FRONT OF MY EYES
IN THIS JUDGING ROOM
AND IN THIS PICTURE, TOO.
SARA.
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS BEAUTIFULLY.
AND SHE LOOKED LIKE
A HOUSEWIFE CLOMPING DOWN
THE AISLE OF THE SUPERMARKET
ON THE CATWALK.
SHE'S GOT THE HEIGHT,
BUT SHE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO USE IT.
I THINK THAT
WHEN YOU'RE 6 FEET TALL,
YOU GOTTA BRING IT.
SHE'S LIKE A LINEBACKER
WHO'S BIG BUT CAN'T TACKLE.
BACK TO THE MALL FOR HER.
- OH.
- BROOKE.
USUALLY, BROOKE'S CHIN
LOOKS SO BIG AND STRONG
IN HER PICTURES,
BUT IT'S--IT'S SEXY THIS TIME.
IT'S NOT AWKWARD.
BROOKE HAS A LOT OF ISSUES
AS WELL.
I MEAN, BROOKE NEEDS TO WAKE UP.
SHE NEEDS TO GET STRONGER,
TOUGHER...
SHE'S MY FAVORITE
BROKE-DOWN MODEL.
CAN SHE BE FIXED?
♪♪♪
EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
♪♪♪
JOANIE.
JOANIE, YOU TAKE CHANCES,
AND THE REASON WHY
YOUR NAME IS CALLED FIRST--
BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE
YOU TOOK THIS WHOLE WEEK
OF SOUL MODELING
AND REALLY USED IT
TO YOUR ADVANTAGE.
AND YOU INCORPORATED IT
INTO THIS PICTURE,
AND YOU INCORPORATED
IT INTO
YOUR SIGNATURE RUNWAY WALK.
SO, BRAVO,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JADE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
NNENNA.
WORK IT.
(laughs)
THERE YA GO!
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
♪♪♪
FURONDA.
THE PARALYZED RIGHT ARM.
UH-OH, STILL PARALYZED.
(laughs)
THE NEXT NAME...
DANIELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
♪♪♪
BROOKE.
BROOKE, YOU, TOO,
HAVE THAT SIGNATURE WALK,
BUT YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT.
YOU'VE GOTTA BELIEVE IT
AND SELL IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL LESLIE AND SARA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
♪♪♪
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL
ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
SARA, THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU
FROM WEEK TO WEEK IN THIS ROOM,
AND THEY SEE TALL.
BUT WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW TO WORK SUPER-TALL,
THEY SEE AWKWARD.
ONE OF THE JUDGES SAID,
"SEND HER BACK TO THE MALL."
♪♪♪
LESLIE, THE JUDGES THINK THAT
YOU MARCH TO YOUR OWN DRUM.
THEY THINK, "BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES."
BUT A LOT OF THEM
DON'T SEE A MODEL
WHEN YOU STAND
IN FRONT OF THEM.
THEY'RE CONCERNED WITH
YOUR POSTURE.
YOUR PRESENCE.
♪♪♪
SARA.
NOT GOING BACK
TO THE MALL YET.
SARA,
YOU HAVE TO OWN YOUR HEIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO ALMOST GET
A LITTLE BRAGGADOCIOUS
UP IN HERE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT?
LIKE...
"HEY."
OWN THAT.
'CAUSE IF YOU DON'T,
IT'S GONNA BE A HINDRANCE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS, LESLIE.
THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
EVEN THOUGH
THE COMPETITION IS STRESSFUL,
YOU STILL WANNA CONTINUE.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THINGS
YOU GET TO EXPERIENCE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE, EVEN
MODELS,
DON'T GET TO EXPERIENCE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT LIKE THAT.
OKAY, BYE, SWEETIE.
THE BIG THING
WAS MY--MY RUNWAY WALK
AND MY PRESENCE.
ONCE I'M THERE,
THEY WANTED TO SEE,
YOU KNOW,
A MODEL STRONG AND CONFIDENT.
AND I DON'T THINK
I SHOWED THEM THAT.
IN THE BACK OF MY MIND,
NOT KNOWING
IF I COULD REALLY DO IT.
AND I--OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
THAT SHOWED.
I TRIED TO GIVE THEM
MY ALL, BUT...
(sniffles)
I GUESS, YOU KNOW,
I JUST--FEELING THAT
MAYBE I WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHAT IS--
THAT'S WHAT'S DISAPPOINTING.
♪♪♪
COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS GET A CHANCE
TO IMPRESS AN IMPORTANT AGENT.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
A TRANSVESTITE.
LOOK AT THAT FACE.
YOU KNOW,
SHE'S PRETTY CUTTHROAT.
THIS IS ONE
OF MY BEST SHOOTS TO DATE.
ECCH.
AND JOANIE'S
QUEST FOR PERFECTION...
WE'RE REALLY GONNA
MOVE THESE FOUR.
TAKES A PAINFUL TURN.
I'VE BEEN
IN THE DENTIST'S OFFICE
FOR 12 HOURS.
♪♪♪